[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american film called bubble
boy
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
a boy named jimmy livingston is born
with no immunity whatsoever even a
little germ can kill him so he has to be
kept in isolation
he cannot touch anything without it
being decontaminated hence he will have
to live inside a bubble-like plastic
sphere for all his life to survive
his mother mrs livingston is
overprotective of her son
until he was four years old he wasn't
even allowed to come home
however after he turned four she and mr
livingston bring the little boy home in
his bubble his room too has a huge
bubble so he can walk inside it the
bubble has a pair of protruded hands
that his parents can use to touch him
all his toys are decontaminated to be
free of the smallest of the germs and
kept inside the bubble
jimmy has lived in that room ever since
mrs livingston doesn't ever want him to
leave the bubble so she ends all the
bedtime stories with the princess dying
because they were let free he is only
allowed to watch one tv channel and read
one magazine because mrs livingston
insists they are the only ones ever made
she also uses the protruded arms to cut
his hair and hug her son
mrs livingston is an extreme nationalist
so she teaches jimmy only the things she
thinks are reasonable and forces her
ideas on him however poor jimmy doesn't
know better so he goes along with it
everyone in the city knows about the
unique bubble boy but it doesn't work to
his advantage
instead the neighbor kids wrap
themselves in plastic wrap and make fun
of jimmy outside his home mrs livingston
chases them away frequently
the only food jimmy eats is homemade a
decontamination system has been placed
in a plastic tube where mrs livingston
places his food to kill the germs before
jimmy can fetch it jimmy is now 16 years
old he narrates that he grew up like any
other kid and is happy when he gets an
electrical guitar instead of a car
until one day he is at his window when
he sees a new girl his age named chloe
moving into his neighborhood he has
grown to like the girl but cannot do
anything about it more so he doesn't
know anything about love or girls his
mother senses his infatuation and
recites the story to jimmy about a boy
who died because he touched the next
door for the next few years he
watches chloe through his windows a lot
she also notices him watching her he
narrates that he knows something is
happening to him but he doesn't know
what
one morning he wakes up with an erection
and is petrified unknown to the concept
he hits himself with a bat he cries and
calls his mother
mrs livingston comes in and makes him
repeat the pledge of allegiance until he
calms down chloe has a group of popular
friends who make fun of jimmy calling
him the bubble boy
she seems to be defensive towards him
one day she knocks on the livingston's
door and mr livingston lets her in
she sees the system of plastic tubes all
around the house and is fascinated
she follows the tube and reaches jimmy's
room
jimmy is surprised and nervous because
his mother is the only woman he has
talked to
chloe talks to him and tells him she
like his guitar
jimmy tries teaching her to play it with
the protruded hands he starts reciting
the pledge of allegiance in the middle
of it
starting that day the two hang out
together every day mrs livingston
doesn't like their friendship but cannot
do anything about it a montage of them
spending time together follows
she gives him a guinea pig inside a ball
for his birthday and even brings kids
inside his room for halloween
one night on her birthday a drunk chloe
sneaks inside jimmy's room through the
windows
she tries getting inside the bubble
claiming she cannot stay away from him
anymore
however she passes out before she can go
in
the scene cuts to chloe's prom night her
perverted boyfriend mark comes to pick
her up and jimmy is devastated
mark offers jimmy a cigarette but he
doesn't know what it is one night jimmy
sees mark and chloe make out through his
windows
the very next day chloe comes into
jimmy's room and shows him her
engagement ring
mark had proposed to her to marry him
their marriage is this weekend at
niagara falls and she has come to inform
jimmy jimmy is disappointed but doesn't
show it in his face
she has also brought him a gift which
she keeps inside his decontamination
tube but jimmy ignores it instead he
gives her the guinea pig back and asks
her to go away chloe leaves with tears
in her eyes
later jimmy opens the gift and sees it
as a snow globe with i love you written
inside
surprised he screams her name and
decides to go to niagara falls to stop
the wedding
he works hard to make himself a portable
bubble shield and is finally successful
then he sneaks out of the house without
his parents knowing jimmy is happy to be
running for the first time he reaches
the bus station and asks the person
there for a bus ticket however jimmy has
forgotten to bring any money distressed
he tries to cross the road when he is
hit by a bus
he goes flying to the ground but his
bubble saves him
the people from the bus come out and
offer to give him a ride
jimmy happily accepts it but he gets to
know that the people are part of a
religious cult when he points it out
they angrily throw him out of the bus
the cult group reaches their destination
where their leader announces a round man
inside a globe to be the savior sent by
god the group realizes that jimmy was
their savior and sets off to look for
him to take him out of the globe
meanwhile jimmy meets a biker named slim
jimmy tells him about the love of his
life marrying someone else
slim is impressed and in turn tells him
of his old girlfriend who he still loves
named wildfire
he then offers jimmy a ride and both of
them make their way to niagara falls
at home mrs livingston finds jimmy
missing and freaks out mrs livingston
and her husband set out to look for
jimmy because the police would only do
it after 24 hours of the disappearance
elsewhere slim and jimmy reach vegas and
stop to rest they have a lot of fun at a
casino but jimmy only has two days
before the wedding
so he leaves slim at the club steals a
scooter and runs away in it
after traveling for a while jimmy comes
across his parents car who tries to stop
him from running in a hurry jimmy gets
into an accident but thankfully his
bubble bounces him into a running train
he escapes his mother but is now trapped
in a train with talents from a freak
show the freaks tell him about their
boss dr freak who keeps them captured
and uses them in his freak show jimmy
meets dr freak who happens to be a dwarf
he accidentally throws the man to the
ground with his bubble and frees the
other freaks
then he continues his way to niagara
falls but he can hardly use a scooter
anymore so he goes to a restaurant to
ask someone for a ride
there a bunch of police officers bully a
man named pushpop
when jimmy tells them he has no immunity
they assume jimmy has a contagious
disease and run away from the place the
restaurant catches on fire in the chaos
and push pop offers jimmy a ride he also
agrees to take him to niagara falls
somewhere else mrs livingston reaches dr
freak who tells her that jimmy is going
to niagara falls
furious she calls chloe and yells at her
for making jimmy run away as she talks
to dr freak the freaks outside steal her
car
push pop and jimmy are on their way when
they hit a cow in the middle of the road
push pop is distressed because in his
religion cows are a symbol of god but
following his mother's word jimmy tells
him that his religion is false
this offends pushback so he leaves jimmy
on his own jimmy then somehow reaches
new york he asks for a ride from an old
man named pippi to which he agrees
jimmy wakes up the next morning and the
man is still driving the car
jimmy soon realizes that pippi is lying
lifeless and the car hits a billboard
jimmy goes into a grocery store and
calls chloe
mark picks up the phone and tells jimmy
to give up because he is about to marry
chloe in an hour
he is now hopeless so he calls his
mother and asks her to come to pick him
both his parents drive to him and get
him inside the car mrs livingston goes
to the washroom when mr livingston asks
jimmy how it felt to be outside for the
first time the father and son bond mr
livingston tells jimmy to not give up
before trying taking his words jimmy
runs to stop the wedding mrs livingston
sees this and follows him in their car
at the same time the cult group finds
jimmy and follows him as well
slim with his biker friends comes to
rescue jimmy too
slim locks eyes with mrs livingston who
happens to be his old love wildfire
turns out all of them are driving on a
plane's runway a plane takes off and
jimmy gets on board with an old pilot
they fly to niagara falls but the plane
crashes making jimmy fall into the
waterfall thankfully his bubble doesn't
let him drown
he somehow manages to get out of the
water and rushes his way to the wedding
chloe and mark are in the chapel saying
their vows when jimmy enters the church
claiming his love for her
seeing this is his last chance to
persuade chloe he puts his life in
danger and tears his bubble open to kiss
her however just after it he falls
unconscious as chloe tries to wake him
up mr and mrs livingston arrive there
too
mrs livingston mourns her son's death
when mr livington asks her to tell
everyone the truth
mrs livingston embarrassingly reveals
that jimmy doesn't have any condition
and he suddenly wakes up
it turns out that she had lied to him to
keep him away from the evils of the
world for all these years
jimmy is shocked but forgives his mother
when she claims she did it to protect
him he finally embraces chloe as
everyone claps
cut to a few months later chloe and
jimmy are getting married
everyone he met during his journey is at
the wedding
mr livingston mrs livingston and slim
are now a throuple the movie ends as we
see jimmy and chloe drive away in a car
to their honeymoon
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching